this could be the beginning of the end
of Decades of conflict azerbaijani
officials and representatives of ethnic
Armenians from nagorna karabakh sit down
to talk they couldn't agree on many
issues like security guarantees and
ending transport blockades but decided
to talk again
the talks follow assurances from
azerbaijan's president that the rights
of ethnic Armenians would be respected
I have said the Armenian population
living in Azerbaijan are our citizens
simply Armenian nationalists war
criminals leaders of Armenia and Karbach
took these people hostage poisoned their
brains the talks were held on armenia's
Independence Day the country's prime
minister addressing the nation
peace should be valued and P should not
be confused with the truce or a
ceasefire peace is an environment that
is free from conflicts Interstate
inter-ethnic conflicts this path is not
easy it goes through external and
internal shocks and we must go through
this path for the sake of Independence
for the sake of statehood for the sake
of the future
hundreds gathering in Yerevan for a
second day saying the Prime Minister has
given up on nagorna karabakh
negotiations come after a lightning
offensive by Azerbaijan in nagorna
karabakh left ethnic Armenian forces
little choice but to agree to negotiate
but until a final agreement is reached
karabakh Armenians say they have been
abandoned Dimitri medvedenko Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera